[Musica]
buonasera a tutti stasera vi parlerò
appunto del castello di mirandola un
percorso archeologico reale e un
tentativo di percorso virtuale
attraverso le colline della val di merse
il castello di milan duolo è un
insediamento medievale che poi si
trasforma in castello e uno scavo
iniziato nel 2001 è proseguito fino al
2016 adesso stiamo iniziando a
progettare tutta la fase di
valorizzazione del contesto dove si
trova in val di merse nel comune di
chiusdino in un paesaggio meraviglioso è
un sito molto difficilmente
raggiungibile ma vicino a un punto
importantissimo dal punto di vista
turistico
ovvero san galgano l'abbazia di san
galgano e montesiepi con la sua famosa
spada nella roccia si trova a una
cinquantina di chilometri da siena
appunto nel comune di giustino ma più
vicino al confine provinciale quindi
sotto cicciano e montieri la fondazione
dell'insediamento è datata nel corso del
settimo secolo e è legata a uno
sfruttamento minerario quindi per la
risorsa metallurgica estrazione di ferro
durante l'ottavo secolo invece si
trasforma in un villaggio agricolo con
due distinti foley di potere che
fondamentalmente erano funzionali alla
conservazione e all'accumulo di derrate
alimentari un grande cambiamento avverrà
nel corso del ix secolo con la
fondazione della multiss in cui diciamo
si distacca dall'insediamento principale
un'area ben definita che tra l'altro è
la più alta del della collina in cui il
potere si barrea e si difende
dall'esterno facendo costruire un grande
fossato e alzando una palizzata
all'interno di questa palizzata si
conservano
quelle che sono le risorse più
importanti il cibo ma anche ferro e
tutta la ricchezza nel corso
dell'undicesimo secolo
il sito si trasforma diventa un castello
quindi si inizia a costruire in pietra
vengono costruite porte torri un palazzo
in cui diciamo era la residenza
signorile la chiesa in in pietra e poi
viene distrutto dal vescovo di volterra
tra il 1100 25 e il 1.133 dopodiché la
storia di milan duolo inizia una lenta
escalation fino all'abbandono
lo scavo ha rappresentato un momento
importante dell'informatica applicata
all'archeologia perché fin dal primo
momento abbiamo avuto una
sperimentazione di tutti software e
tutte applicazioni per analizzare e
divulgare dati gis webgis database
alfanumerici fotografici sito web
appunto per diffondere i dati è
chiaramente una delle prime pagine di
facebook in particolare però ci siamo
contraddistinti per l'uso del laser
scanner e abbiamo realizzato dal 2004 e
il 2011 scansione su quasi tutta la
collina dove avevamo scavato fino a quel
momento il problema vero per contesti
stratigrafici come può essere appunto
uno scavo archeologico è che il laser
scanner genera troppe informazioni
miliardi di punti che però hanno i
fondamentalmente diventano anche
ridondanti quindi quello e abbiamo
pensato è che forse la fotogrammetria
era l'elemento che serviva più al nostro
caso l'origine della fotogrammetria la
fotogrammetria nasce da un applicazione
della stereoscopia è una teoria scoperta
nel nell'ottocento e una tecnica per
realizzare la visione di immagini e
trasmettere una sensazione di
tridimensionalità e la fonte
d'ispirazione è la vista binoculare
sostanzialmente i nostri occhi essendo
in due posizioni distinte vedono gli
oggetti in due modi diversi ma ciò che
vedono gli occhi non è ciò che riesce a
elaborare il nostro cervello e il nostro
cervello ci dà l'illusione la sensazione
di vedere una tridimensionalità anche
dove l'occhio il singolo occhio non
riesce a percepirla la fotogrammetria
appunto sono dei software che fanno
esattamente questo si scattano tutta una
serie di molte immagini intorno a un
oggetto e attraverso nella lavorazione
un elaborazione al computer si riesce a
ricostruire un modello tridimensionale
come fa il software sostanzialmente che
è molto automatizzato riesce a
riconoscere i vari punti dell'oggetto
quindi analizza fotogramma per
fotogramma e li posiziona nello spazio
sia gli oggetti i punti e noi vediamo
sia la posizione della macchina
fotografica costruisce prima una nuvola
di punti quindi tutti questi punti
singoli compongono poi l'oggetto seconda
fase
triangolazione di questi punti per
costruire una superficie terza fase
spalmare sopra a questa superficie noi
abbiamo una fotografia tridimensionale
uno dei progetti che secondo me
e andato molto nella direzione che noi
vogliamo percorrere è stato wastewater
web ovvero doveva essere questo progetto
sostanzialmente una valorizzazione della
promozione attraverso la creazione di un
percorso turistico della rete rete
idrica medievale di siena appunto i
bottini quindi come come era il processo
il processo era scansionare
tridimensionalmente tramite laser
scanner e fotogrammetria questi cunicoli
e farli per percorrere in superficie da
dai turisti tramite una mobile app gli
elementi fondamentali di questo progetto
e che credo che fossero sicuramente
all'avanguardia e che vale la pena
sottolineare sono quattro
sostanzialmente una valorizzazione di
percorsi periferici all'interno della
città esterni ai luoghi che tutti noi
conosciamo e che sono i due poli
principali di attrazione sugli stadi
sera ovvero il duomo e piazza del campo
una valorizzazione di questi beni
architettonici e storico architettonici
l'abbattimento delle un aiuto per i
diversamente abili di per riuscire a
percorrere questi cunicoli in qualche
modo che naturalmente non possono essere
frequentati e possono essere frequentati
anche poco da dai turisti
insomma e poi soprattutto una
valorizzazione una sensibile
sensibilizzazione sui temi dell'acqua
che in una città come siena dove non
non c'era un accesso diretto alle fonti
idriche era estremamente importante
quindi appunto la diciamo il progetto si
sostanziava con la costruzione di questi
modelli se dimensionali è un
applicazione che ti faceva per correre
sulle strade attuali di siena il
percorso di questi di questi bottini dal
dalle fonti fino alle periferie
sostanzialmente quindi questo è un po è
stato un po anche un punto di partenza e
una best practice per noi il lavoro che
anche in questi giorni e stiamo facendo
appunto è portare il rilievo
tridimensionale deve essere un po il il
volano per la valorizzazione del sito
quindi stiamo scattando fotografie di
tutti gli oggetti su per i palazzi mura
case eccetera eccetera per ricostruire i
modelli tridimensionali
oltre a questo stiamo facendo dei voli
sopra la collina con un drone per avere
il modello digitale del terreno e quindi
lo stato lo stato attuale di tutta la
collina appunto attraverso la reazione
prima di una nuova nuvola di punti poi
di una match e infine di una texture
fotografica di una punto immagine se
dimensionale che c
ci possa offrire appunto questo questo
risultato
quello che è importante oltre
all'aspetto del rilievo di fersen è che
in realtà è questa
questo è questo software queste queste
applicazioni possono essere la base di
partenza per la costruzione di modelli
di modelli interpretati in qualche modo
quindi di ricostruzioni tridimensionali
perché uno dei grandissimi problemi
dell'archeologia in generale
ora superando lo siamo un pò facilitati
perché abbiamo grandi murature abbiamo
la cinta muraria la porta le furie
quindi diciamo la percezione del turista
riesce in qualche modo a cogliere la
grandezza delle strutture ma in molti
altri contesti
questa cosa sfugge non riusciamo a
capire perché spesso abbiamo pure in
terra e basta quindi è molto
impercettibile invece attraverso le
ricostruzioni di possiamo trasmettere al
visitatore comunque la sensazione di
quello che doveva essere l'insediamento
in vita di quello che
noi abbiamo scavato di quello che noi
abbiamo capito e di quello che noi
abbiamo individuato sostanzialmente è
un'esperienza ma non deve essere
l'esperienza finale perché ci siamo resi
conto questo un po all'università dopo
il primo l'entusiasmo della
tridimensionalità della grafica 3d si è
resa conto che in realtà è un'esperienza
molto bella impattante ma che ha il
limite fisico di discostare dalla realtà
cioè se arriva a un certo punto in cui
si preferisce guardare il modello 3d non
visitare il sito archeologico il
monumento perché tanto come dice ma io
lo guardo al computer e non ho nessun
tipo di problema in realtà è un modo per
dissociare realtà e diciamo aspetti
virtuali
una soluzione potrebbe essere quella di
realizzare dei percorsi reali e virtuali
insieme lo strumento che abbiamo pensato
e che diciamo è molto
utilizzato in questo periodo è la realtà
virtuale è un visore che si mette
davanti agli occhi nella sua generazione
più nella sua applicazione più semplice
e con un cellulare che si che s infila
appunto all'interno di questa maschera
io ruotando la testa a 360 gradi che
puoi vedere l'ambiente intorno a te come
se fosse posizionato all'interno del
monumento o dello scavo archeologico e
guardare tutto quello che hai
diciamo appunto intorno a te che puoi
vedere quindi puoi vedere attraverso
anche magari alcune ricostruzioni questo
è un modo per essere per fondere insieme
le due realtà è un po quello che stanno
provando a fare per esempio a roma al
colosseo in cui ci sono dei punti ben
precisi in cui si può indossare la
maschera e poi vedere quello quello che
vedi anche senza la maschera troppo la
maschera la vedi ricostruito quindi
quando il colosseo era in vita quindi
una sensazione è in qualche modo che
fonde le due realtà che riesce a
valorizzare il risultato di tutto il
processo storico che ha portato alla
scoperta degli archeologi ma anche tutto
il processo storico della vita
dell'insediamento del monumento e
dell'oggetto
tutto questo considerate che ha dei
costi relativamente bassi e questo è una
una cosa molto importante anche perché
diciamo quello che vogliamo fare è
sviluppare nuovi percorsi economici e
nuovi spazi per la ricerca
credo che ricerca archeologica sviluppo
informati o debbano andare nella
direzione di favorire
ricerca fruizione ma sopra le comunità
ei territori ma soprattutto uno sviluppo
economico che passa attraverso gli enti
pubblici che sono proprietari spesso dei
beni società private e la diciamo
imprenditori operatori culturali che
possano collaborare all'interno della
costruzione di queste nuove zone di
questi parchi archeologici ma anche
anche altri sviluppo di monumenti
eccetera eccetera
come mai perché la vera sfida non è
quella di creare un bel modello
tridimensionale o rilievo
fotogrammetrico quello che noi dobbiamo
fare è dimostrare a giulio tremonti ea
baracco ma obama solo per citare due che
hanno pronunciato queste parole che noi
o con la cultura non vogliamo mangiarci
vogliamo sviluppare il pil dell'italia
questo è la vera sfida perché
l'opportunità c'è una su tutti è l'art
bonus che in qualche modo conosciamo
quindi una sfida importante
una sfida determinante per il paese è un
gioco dove l'italia deve investire e che
può vincere ma il rischio grosso è che
qui o si vince o si muore
grazie per l'attenzione
[Applauso]
[Musica]